[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the announcement of a new
harry potter show that will be released
on hbo
actually two shows over the years there
seem to have always been whisperings of
new harry potter content being released
particularly on hbo and it seems like
every year fans are left disappointed
when once again nothing new is released
the reality of a tool is that we hit a
massive harry potter dry spell with the
last harry potter film being released 10
years ago and the last fantastic beast
film being released in 2018. in essence
we've been left wanting more but the
good news is that there's plenty on the
horizon this comes in the form of a new
film a new game and two shows i'm going
to cover them all the new film coming
april 2022 is the recently announced
fantastic piece 3 the secrets of
dumbledore which is most likely a third
installment in a five-part series yet to
be confirmed the new game hogwarts
legacy which will likely be released
shortly after the film is an rpg that
boasts an impressive open world format
allowing players to approach the
wizarding world how they see fit
in this game players will see the
wizarding world in a completely new
light as the game is set over 100 years
before harry ever steps foot in hogwarts
now i mentioned two shows above so let's
dive into the first one the first rumor
relating to a potential harry potter
show came out earlier this year a harry
potter live-action tv series is in early
development at hbo max sources tell the
hollywood reporter that executives at
the warner media backstreamer have
engaged in multiple conversations with
potential writers exploring various
ideas that would bring the beloved
property to television live action
sounds amazing but unfortunately this
idea was more or less shot down in a
follow-up article however it turned out
that the rumors weren't entirely untrue
there was going to be a harry potter
show being released just not quite in
the format that you'd have expected
coming first to hbo is a harry potter
quiz show the show will feature two
wizarding world tv specials that will
cover a five night harry potter trivia
event this event is to celebrate the
20th anniversary of the film release of
harry potter and the philosopher's stone
the event itself will see harry potter
superfans gearing up and competing
against each other in harry potter
themed trivia it also looks like we're
nearing the release of the show now
which comes at the end of this month
okay now on to dps the resistance the
cast reunion in a trailer recently
released by the wizarding world fans
were met with the news that hbo are
going to be hosting an hbo max special
in celebration of 20 years of harry
potter the special will feature a
massive cast reunion and notably the
reunion of the trio daniel radcliffe
emma watson and rupert grint harry
potter's 20th anniversary returned to
hogwarts will premiere on hbo max on new
year's day january 1st 2022 the feature
will tell an enchanting making of story
through all new in-depth interviews and
cast conversations according to hbo max
other actors from the beloved franchise
expected to join will include helena
bottom carter robbie coltrane ray fines
jason isaacs gary oldman imelda staunton
tom felton james phelps oliver phelps
mark williams bonnie wright alfred enoch
matthew lewis yvonne lynch and ian hart
this retrospective is a tribute to
everyone whose lives were touched by
this cultural phenomenon from the
talented cast and crew who poured their
heart and soul into this extraordinary
film franchise to the passionate fans
who continued to keep the wizarding
world spirit alive 20 years later said
tom ascheim president of warner bros
global kids young adults and classics
the show will hit our screens january
1st are you excited comment down below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you